et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mois encore et
aujourd'hui on va répondre à cette
question est ce que ce petit drôle le dj
house park est le meilleur drones de
nigeria
ouais enfin on répond à la question
répond à la question on répond à la
question après l'intro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réponse vous l'attendez est ce que
c'est le meilleur est ce que c'est pas
le meilleur mais c'est un petit peu
compliqué en fait de répondre à ça on va
faire ça point par point parce que dans
la vie tout n'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir il n'ya pas le meilleur et puis les
autres
en fait ce que vous allez penser de ce
drone ça va sûrement dépendre de vos
usages mais alors juste avant de
commencer je vous laisse lire ceci et
moi j'attends là en fait deux minutes
voilà allez c'est parti
alors on va distinguer deux cas de
figure il ya d'un côté les
professionnels et de l'autre côté les
amateurs
on va laisser de côté le côté
professionnel puisque ce n'est pas un
côté que je maîtrise particulièrement
mais par contre si vous êtes amateurs
que vous faites des vidéos pour youtube
ou des vidéos juste personnel et que
vous avez envie d'investir dans un drone
et ben on va se pencher un petit peu sur
la question qu'est ce qui est
intéressant ou pas sur la ganja lyon va
prendre les trois plus connu le fantôme
le mavic et le spark alors le fantôme
moi je le dégage tout de suite pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'il est super
encombrants grosso modo si vous partez
quelque part que vous vous dites tiens
je peux être faire une vidéo je vais
prendre mon drones au cas où le fantôme
vous oublié parce qu'il est très
encombrant que c'est pas un truc qu'on
met dans son sac en se disant peut-être
que je vais tourner une vidéo mais je
sais pas trop clairement c'est quelque
chose qui doit être réfléchi on sort un
fantôme vraiment pour aller tourner
quand on est sûr de ce qu'on va aller
tourner et moi clairement je veux plus
tôt m un drone dans mon sac en disant on
verra bien ce qui se passe peut-être
j'aurai besoin de faire des plans donc
je me le prends au cas où est donc
clairement le fantôme on peut le sortir
de cette catégorie là on le prend pas ou
comme ce qui nous laisse de rendre à
comparer le maviepro et le sparc et ça
tombe bien je les ai testés tous les
deux alors côté caractéristiques
principales le mavi pro film en 4k il a
un stabilisateur trois ans est aussi
permet de filmer en log
c'est ce mode dont on a parlé dans une
précédente vidéo qui va permettre de
faire des retouches colorimétrique plus
poussé que si on filme en mode normal et
question autonomie une batterie de ma
vie que ça dure entre 20 et 25 minutes
sinon en dehors de ça les
fonctionnalités sont à peu près les même
si ce n'est qu'on peut piloter le spark
avec des gestes
avec la main ce qui est dans mon cas pas
forcément utile qui fait un petit peu
gadget et il n'a pas à servir forcément
à faire des super plan d'eau où deux
poteaux et donc le sport qui lui ne
filme que en 1080p qui est stabilisé
certes mais avec un stabilisateur de
taxe uniquement le mode blog n'est pas
présent dans le spark peut-être une mise
à jour futures le donnera accès mais
pour l'instant ce n'est pas possible et
la batterie du spark tient environ 10 à
15 minutes donc sur le papier qu'est ce
qu'ils gagnent avait techniquement c'est
le mavic et pourtant j'ai revendu mon
magic pour prendre ce petit bonhomme là
est la raison elle est simple c'est que
il est ultra petit ça tient vraiment
dans la main vraiment c'est un drône
qu'on va pouvoir balancer dans son sac
qu'on va pouvoir emmener partout on voir
sortir uniquement aux besoins et
finalement les spécificités techniques
vont rentrer assez peu en ligne de
compte
la 4 car mes vidéos jeux les exportant
1080 p g exportant hd je fais pas de 4k
donc forcément ça m'apporte pas quelque
chose de fantastique
de ce point de vue là du point de vue de
la stabilisation si on part pas dans des
espèces de pirouettes acrobatiques les
deux axes vont suffire largement la
plupart du temps le mode log
ouais j'aurais quand même bien aimé la
voir sur le spark parce que ça permet
d'avoir une image bien plus jolie après
quand on fait du post traitement et la
batterie de 10 minutes et ben j'en ai
pris deux et ma foi j'ai rarement fait
même avec le mavic des vols de plus de
20 minutes parce que j'ai pas forcément
besoin d'avoir énormément de plans
deux drones c'est vraiment juste pour
situer certaines vidéos et puis voilà
faire de belles images de temps en temps
quand je pars en voyage mais vidéo ne
sont pas des vidéos qui sont consacrés
aux drones c'est vraiment un petit plus
pour ajouter à ce que je fais déjà donc
sans hésitation même si la qualité vidéo
elle est un petit peu moindre quand même
il faut pas se leurrer c'est un drone à
600 euros aux parents ma vie qui en vaut
plus que mille la qualité est un petit
peu moins bonne mais entre un drone que
je vais sortir super facilement que je
vais voilà lancés et puis faire ma
petite prise et ramener puis terminer je
le range dans le sac on n'en parle plus
et un autre qui va être un peu plus
délicat à sortir qui va être même si le
mavi que ça reste quand même facile
assorti on est bien d'accord mais c'est
un tout petit peu plus encombrant
je préfère avoir un drone que je vais
utiliser qu'un drone que je vais avoir
du mal à sortir
alors il faut savoir que le spark le
modèle de base et wifi donc il n'ya pas
de télécommande ça ce pilote directement
avec un smartphone ou avec les gestes de
la main mais je vous recommande vivement
de prendre le pack fly mort avec la
radiocommande et avec les batteries
supplémentaires tout simplement parce
que quand vous le piloter en wifi la
portée est vraiment réduite je crois que
c'est de l'ordre de 50 mètres donc on va
pas pouvoir faire grand chose et que la
deuxième batterie elle est à mon sens
complètement indispensable parce que dix
minutes ça passe très très vite et on
peut vite être frustré même si petit
truc sympa on a un petit port usb juste
à l'arrière de du drone qui va permettre
de le charger directement éventuellement
avec une batterie externe donc pas
forcément besoin d'avoir une prise de
courant à proximité pour pouvoir le
chargé enfin juste pour finir je vous
rappelle que faire voler un drone s'est
pas anodin il ya une législation autour
de ça on peut pas le faire voler
n'importe où on fera une vidéo
rapidement je l'espère pour faire le
point un petit peu là dessus sur la
législation sur où on peut faire voler
un drone les mesures de sécurité etc
mais surtout faites attention un drone
un objet volant qui peut tomber et
éventuellement blesser des gens donc
fait attention et volent et surtout en
sécurité et voilà les amis c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu si c'est le cas vous
pouvez mettre un petit pouce en l'air si
vous êtes nouveau sur la chaîne et que
vous ne voulez rien rater de la suite
vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant sur
le petit bouton qui s'affichera au
milieu de l'écran et moi je vous dis
comme d'habitude à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
[Musique]